every time you watch a thunderstorm
outside your window you're witnessing
the energy of an atomic bomb
now imagine harvesting that raw energy
and using it to power the planet but how
is lightning created would you have your
own lightning collector and why aren't
we currently doing it this is what if
and here's what would happen if we power
the planet with lightning let's say like
solar panels you could install a small
lightning Harvester in your backyard it
might be ugly but pretty soon you'd be
jumping for joy every time there's a
lightning storm all you would need is a
single bolt of lightning and you could
power your house for a whole month that
would be a shocking savings on your
electricity bill but how would we power
the whole world first we'd install
massive metal towers at some of
lightnings highly visited areas imagine
monolithic towers rising from Lake
Maracaibo in Venezuela this lake is the
most electric place on earth and during
the peak rainy season it's possible to
see an average of 28 lightning flashes
per minute
we'd also installed a lightning
Harvester
next to santa's tower in the Swiss Alps
this cell tower gets hit by lightning
about 100 times a year winning the title
for most frequently struck
[Music]
all 100 bolts of lightning were
collected at Santa's tower that would be
100 million to 100 billion volts of
electricity every year still we couldn't
just rely on these electric hotspots it
would largely depend on you the average
person to harvest lightning for
electricity much like solar panels
homeowners would elect to install
lightning towers in their backyards or
on top of their houses
keeping the source close to where it's
needed there would also be small
lightning farms scattered around rural
areas much like wind farms today these
large metal structures would be an
eyesore on a normal day but would be
magnificent
during a storm the countries where
lightning strikes the most the United
States India and Colombia to name a few
would become the Centers for lightning
harvesting after using this clean energy
to power their own countries they would
sell off the rest of the energy to other
nations
but how is lightning created in the
first place
Thunder clouds are made up of millions
and millions of water droplets and ice
which collide together during all those
collisions electrons are knocked loose
and gather at the bottom of the clouds
this creates a negative charge in the
lower part of the cloud while the upper
cloud becomes positively charged the
separation of negative and positive
charges results in an electrical field
when this electrical field becomes
strong enough the surrounding air
ionizes creating positive and negative
ions
the negative ions create a path to earth
called a step leader when the negative
ions in a step leader find the positive
ions of an object on the ground let's
say a lightning Harvester it strikes and
in this scenario that energy is
collected and stored for use but how
close are we to developing this
technology well not very close at all
in 2007 alternative Energy Holdings
designed a tower with grounding wires
and a capacitor but their attempts to
harvest energy from lightning failed the
project was too costly and there were
many limitations to its success
lightning is by nature sporadic so it
isn't a sure thing that a bolt will hit
a harvester during a storm if it does
find its target lightning disperses
energy on its way down to earth so a
tower would only capture a fraction of
the energy from a lightning bolt
the bolts themselves aren't
unpredictable and can range wildly from
a hundred million volts of energy to 1
billion volts of energy this would
require a specially engineered collector
that could withstand such a wide range
without exploding and causing fires even
if we were able to successfully harvest
lightning and store the energy for
future use we'd only be able to power
eight percent of American homes that's a
far cry from powering the whole planet
but it's still clean energy and could be
a piece of the entire renewable energy
puzzle if we really wanted to make
lightning our sole source of energy we
need to figure out a way to control the
weather but that's a story for another
what if
[Music]